boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are still at Ko fires the Congress on
the future of engineering software for
our second annual partnership with them
we are very excited and I'll be sitting
down with dr. Oleg Novitsky hello well
thanks for coming on to the show really
appreciate it
I'm very excited to talk to you about
Bill of Materials this is a very
interesting thing open bomb is the
company that you're the co-founder and
CEO of this is the last three and a half
years for you with open bomb and also
doing the last ten years as well as a
blogger and social media advisor at
beyond PLM too which is very cool so
will it will be unpacking both of these
things throughout the conversation like
how did you get involved in engineering
software and where how did it like pique
your interest and then how did you pick
where you want to be get involved oh
that's a very good question it has
happened long time ago and the
originally I wanted to be an architect
and somehow I also wanted to deal with
computers so many many years ago
somebody told that the computer-aided
design is actually when I can take
architecture and computers together so
believe it or not it was kind of 35
years ago and I'm still in this and then
when you were first you do 35 years ago
when you're learning that you can take
architecture and you can take these
designs and put it into digital form and
then be able to you tinker with them in
the digital space what was kind of the
the moment for you that was like whoa
this is going to impact so much how did
that how did that come up and where did
you exactly see yourself fitting into
the the picture i I don't think I
realized it back those days but
in 1885 in 86 so it was about AutoCAD
that was very easy and beautiful they
run on PC computers that was the only
thing that was available for me living
back in the Soviet Union so it's kind of
amazing stuff that instead of drawing on
the desk the board I was able to get
other kid and do some stuff and then
also do programming so I think it's all
started there and then it's gets even
more interesting today than everything
else yeah as the tech has gotten better
your ability to manipulate the digital
sphere has gotten more interesting then
how did how did it evolve then you know
you've being involved in this 35 years
how did it evolve over time all the way
up until where you're at now well it
evolved with the step so I think it was
not 35 years I think it was a little bit
less I'm not as old but I think it's
it's it's when in in different
trajectories so one trajectory was
obviously technological because I like
my roots are in technology and that's
what I was doing when I
lived in Israel for many years I work
for Autodesk resellers as the first time
that I realize it's not only about
writing programs but also going to
customers and trying to sell them those
programs it was my first and attempt to
merge technology and business because
you need to sell what you do and then
second time I was working at the system
and it's part of the challenge I was
promoted to be a CTO and I've been told
that you we made great acknowledged e
but now go to customers and explain them
so that was that was a challenge to go
to customer and explain technology so
that was the moment of time I started my
blog beyond PLM because I realized that
to explain technology is a challenge by
itself so it's not it doesn't doesn't
stop with the great technology it's it's
actually just the beginning because you
need to go to customers potential
customers and sell them to this
technology and explain them the value so
that was that was the moment of time I
also started to blog and that was also
realization that technologies as good as
that can make it value for customers and
that's that's very convenient it's very
important to have that that moment of oh
I translating what I'm doing here into
applications for real world purposes and
talking to industry about how they can
use it for the betterment of their
processes is is very important I'm glad
you're identifying that and and and with
the blog then you're able to get even
more reach than just one-on-one
conversation but now you can go 1-2
thousands and more with the with the
blogging on the project so then ok so
now we are we find ourselves you know at
doing open bomb product centric business
tool for manufacturing so you kind of
went through these the the steps of
seeing the the field progress and then
you're like I want to take reins and
make my own so teach us about that yeah
one was also discovery of the problem
and finding solution and we are not done
yet by any means is just just the
beginning it's just the beginning of the
story but the way it started is that
Bill of Materials I have a question
because baraka channel is so exciting
it's like everything around us like we
can pick anything in this room like this
kappa yes camera of course yes this
chair has yes and this is also explained
to us and your sneakers so also even
these guys yes even this day every scene
has build materials so it's not all the
same it's not all brackets and plates
and screws yeah but it's it's all as
build material it's actually the best
way to explain to our materials its food
okay I take also his bill of materials
your cake has bill of materials because
basically you think about components and
ingredients you're taking them together
you bind them you're bringing them
together you mixing them you're baking
them and then you get the product so
think about this if you think about
manufacturing from that standpoint
anything it's like food okay so it's
like a recipe exactly so you think about
this bill of materials it's it's live
blood so you cannot do anything in this
world without new materials some people
like to call it some people like to call
it differently but it doesn't matter so
that's was the thing that make me really
excited because that's that's the
foundation that the digital like people
come people like to call it digital but
fundamentally it's about data so it's
Dana foundation of everything that you
do if you don't have it you cannot do it
you cannot plan it you cannot buy it you
cannot assembly it you can't do anything
so that was the beginning and then I
realize that many many many
manufacturing companies I knew it from
experience are ending up with excels and
that was a really painful problem that
I've seen for many years and again it's
very long problem but the opportunity
that I've seen is to come with the tool
which is enabled by cloud technologies
and enabled by new technologies
that can make it easy and available and
affordable for everyone so if you think
about this the open BOM is an
opportunity to many manufacturing
companies to stop using excel and to
start collaborate using digital tools so
a typical prospect for open Bom
it's a manufacturing company small
manufacturing company that is having
practice going from u.s. to Europe to
China because the the manufacturing is
different today in the past the Ford
factory had one giant factory that was
making Ford automobiles and from the
left side you get iron and glass and
from the right side it was coming
automobile yeah and today it's all
contractors suppliers and it's all
global crazy so and when small company
can realize the power of internet
connection and contract manufacturing
and talents across the globe they
obviously doing it right but here's the
thing then they taking the material's
placing them in Excel sending them in
the email and got lost because I sent my
build materials to contractor in China
and by the time he got it I already made
the change change and by the way I also
made a mistake and I sent the wrong one
but I didn't realize so they are doing
something and I am doing something and
be completely not on the same bomb so
the open bomb is a technology allowing
you to stay on the same bomb so everyone
is on the same on the same data yes so
and that's the one fundamental part of
both materials and the open mom is a
technology ok I have a couple questions
first is it's so interesting here you
talk about how Ford had a won the the
car manufacturing facility Factory were
you know iron and glass out one side car
up the other side that's so interesting
compared to now in the globalized world
where it's now pieces and contractors
all around that's so fascinating and
then it's also very important when if
you if you can't meet with the internet
with this connectivity that we have now
to have technology where we can
an update that goes live to everyone and
not have these oops moments of oh I have
the wrong bomb over on this side so okay
now now teaches is is bombed the Bill of
Materials is that part of the the
product lifecycle management the PLM is
that one part of the PLM how does how
does that work
that's another great question because if
you ask somebody about what is PLM you
from single person you can get two
answers its depends if it's in the
morning now you're asking two people
you're gonna end up with five so clearly
I'm it's really discipline that is very
hard to define because it depends on
people for somebody is the business
discipline for somebody is technology
for somebody is a product so it's also
again I want to come back to what I've
been experiencing for many years there
are some people who just don't get it
and the people that you know the the the
a our objective is to make products and
they can't wrap their head around the
complex definition of PLM they just said
we don't need it you know I talk to
small manufacturing companies they said
we don't understand it but they
understand simple things so yeah a
simplification it's really big deal in
my view because the complexity hurts
people and I think one of the problems
of PLM although it's a great idea
brilliant technology and excellent
companies it's way too complex for
everyone and it doesn't work for
everyone because of the complexity
interesting it's very much oriented and
a lot of consulting it's very much
oriented and the organizational change
so it's fine but you know it depends on
who you talking to it depends on your
customers like I said if if you need to
explain the value of technology
you can choose simple words of if you
can choose simple words why not so
people understand bond at least this is
my conclusion for the group of customers
that we are working with actually the
way we explain open bomb is there is a
product centric business tool is because
we are not only doing bombs the recent
recent recent addition to open bomb his
ability to manage vendors and ability to
manage purchase orders
he's a wise saw because small company
wants to have an end-to-end process and
for them Bill of Materials it's a rich
recipe for purchasing and if they don't
have this recipe they don't know what to
buy it is they have a long recipe they
bind wrong stops yes so the cake will
not be a cake it'll be something else
yes yes
so from it's important I think the
pilgrim is just probably doesn't fit
definition of everyone company okay
interesting
and then because to me someone that's
you know very much a newbie that is
trying to understand what's what's going
on in the in the engineering software
world to hear the acronyms and then to
be able to try and place them into where
they make most sense is something that
you know like we were discussing earlier
you're like you mentioned it's important
to make certain reductions in complexity
to make the general public be more
understanding of what's actually going
on when you give the example of a cake
being baked with the width of building
materials this makes perfect sense that
you need the right ingredients for the
chair to be made or for the table to be
made the cameras etc so walk us through
these industry examples so if we do want
to make chair table tripod camera if we
want to make this we need we need our
team then needs to use something like
open BOM to be able to all have the
right components to make the camera
written down sourced the raw materials
from the right location so we're able to
find where those are coming from being
sent all to the manufacturing facility
where it gets assembled you have this
the kid the CAD is also the the all the
computer designs are also part of open
BOM as well so does open BOM cover this
like whole spectrum even to the
customers you were you were giving us
the example of the vendors at the very
end as well so can you give us what an
industry example would look like sure
but the the thing that you need to
realize is that your example is
perfectly fine but generalized yeah so
the specifics that the things are
different than the revision details
especially when you come to
manufacturing country so you need to
differentiate between probably three
fundamental type of manufacturing
processes and one if you build to stock
its for example when your company is
doing many microphones and you sell them
based on demand and Amazon so you build
those microphones and another example is
that when you making complex cars and
you configure them based on order and
another example is a complex industrial
equipment that is engineered based on
the requirements of customer so you can
think about these three use cases and
the manufacturing process will be
different in each of these three
specific use cases but this is how you
can classify it so based on the each of
these requirements the practice will be
different so in one whether you will be
building two stock you don't have a more
or less a standard design that you will
be building all the time and you don't
optimize your process so when it will be
completely custom engineering project to
build something it will be different
right but what is the common between all
of them that you do need to have this
recipe of the parts and relationships
and related information and that's what
the Bill of Materials about so it can
look slightly different in all cases the
process around can be slightly different
depends on how many contractors you will
be using you also get different but
fundamentally it's will be very similar
things and many and it's why benefaction
companies are struggling with these
problems a lot because for them
communication
and practice optimization is one of
those that important because when you
have two systems working independently
and two companies working independently
the information is lost and there are
practices not optimal so when when we
take the different processes that are
happening at a company and then you dis
open bum then try and integrate the
communication with the design and the
manufacturing and the CRM does it try
and integrate across yes what what open
bomb does its first of all create a data
foundation and second is automating some
of this manual tasks so if you you've
been talking about kit so typical design
you have your CAD files and you need to
create bird material so in the
traditional form engineer go export data
to excel and send it there's a Nemo very
painful and then the changes are coming
and it's needs to be extracted one time
and many are we copied to another place
so this is the first place where
open-palm gives you a big advantage
because we automate this process so we
extract data from ken automatically
using our integrations and we keep it in
sync so everything happens in kab
automatically come in to open bomb test
everything that you do in open bomb is
merged with the updates is coming from
Ken so eliminating menial tasks
automating processes so now let's move
forward we manage catalogs of all parts
also standard also engineer shoes and we
manage a quantity on hand for small shop
they not need to know how many parts do
they have and then they take in order
they need to know how many they need to
order so we create another instance of
what is called training one or order man
so this planning one order one
it's basically scaled bill of materials
for number of units that you want to
make we automate this task we
automatically calculate how many parts
are missing
so and then this planning bomb is
actually a view that allows you to see
how many parts you have and how many
parts are missing and then you're taking
it in two weights and one you can say if
I need to have an if I have an order of
100 I need to order this number of parts
based on my planning map but I can take
it in reverse and many operational
managers can ask so how many units I can
ship without ordering anything it's also
built on the information that we have so
we can run it in reverse in two things
and it is kind of decision point for
manufacturing company and then the last
but not least now all we need to make
purchase orders so they can be taking
this planning bomb and automating
creating a purchase order so you can
think about draining bomb that requires
to need to be split to 2530 orders for
different contractors so it somehow
needs to be automated and sent out this
is another place where we automate and
we not requiring any copy/paste
separation because this is where our
mistakes are happy look I see I see
people in the evenings that doing some
other job in manufacturing company in
the evening coming to website and
ordering parts because that's that's the
way small shop works yeah so that's
that's the way so we created data
process that automated and connected and
that's what makes
company more efficient yeah I like how
you explained it as you start with data
foundation and then you work on the
getting rid of some of the the tasks
where there is also not only a lot of
human labor involved but a lot of human
error involved absolutely and then when
you when you learn how to how to make
this all seamless and frictionless
process more people can spend time being
creative at doing their best work
I like how you explained how when you
when you take the CAD file and you move
it over into into Excel that when when
not only do you have to then potentially
have someone else from around the world
when you when they take a look at it if
there's been a change made then that
Excel needs to be updated when they view
it it's it's basically like starting at
the data level of the CAD file itself
and that's and that's that's super
crucial now okay so now with the with
what you're doing with the with the Bill
of Materials with this data as well as
the automation processes where do you
see this now going in you know you talk
we talked a little bit about the 30
years that kind of built up and till
this point where is it going from here
it seems like everything is moving to
the cloud and making putting our what we
want to be processed into the cloud and
doing like all the different services
from there this is that part of open
Baum's future that's you see this is
very technological explanation yes so
what I would like it's more visionary
explanation about where it will take us
based on something that you know so if
you this day is going to buy something
so where you go you go to go said so
think about manufacturing companies in
10 15 years they go to open bound micron
because based on you know if you know
the recipe you know what you need and if
you know what you need you can optimize
so the open bomb of the platform can
analyze information of many products we
can make recommendation to people about
what to buy and where to buy if we
manage vendors we can help companies to
choose right-hander's so that's the
information that intertwined connected
and providing business value so exactly
like we absolutely no question the
business value for us of Amazon go in
and figure out what we need to buy a
particular stuff because we know who is
using it and who liked it and what is
the Colston we know all the stuff it's
it's almost natural for us it's ten
years ago it was not natural ten years
ago we've been going to the near nearest
sharp we are asking opinion what is this
and is it mean and so today we don't do
it today we you know I look people in
the in the in the store go in with the
phones and checking against the phone
so manufacturing companies that are the
same just they go in to transform in the
in the in the network you know I would
call it manufacturing Network where
everyone is intertwined interconnected
based on business relationships and the
role of open bar will be to help them to
operate in this digit
and then when you when you give us this
vision of one being able to find a part
that they desire for their for their
manufacturing process when is it is it
as simple as me having that be updated
in my in my CAD file and then of me
being able to see how much that part
costs from open BOM as well where you
have a data set based on that part how
much it cost where it's gonna be sourced
from how that affects the model is this
yeah yes yes and no first of all for
example calculation and cost role it's
even today's simple with open Bom
because we have calculation formulas and
they allow you to roll up cost it's by
itself like hard thing to them but if
you start thinking about transformation
of the entire system you need to think
globally about existing relationships
and this is where the hard that
complicated changes is becoming because
you know digitally everything is simple
mmm but human to human changes like I
was buying from John my entire life and
now I've learned that I am overpaying
twice to John so what are we gonna do
about this yeah so that's that that's
the challenge it was the new person and
we like the new company and how to
organize a sure it comes all complicated
just like they'll take a look on the
changes that happening with some digital
form of transportation like uber
somebody is happy and somebody's angry
like that's that's the most complicated
thing is it
and change will happen in manufacturing
companies because the relationships will
be broken and some relationships will be
optimized them that still will drive the
change that's why it will not happen
overnight although you can say
technology is available yes technology
is available but it will take change and
some of these changes will take time but
no no question it will come it's very
interesting the human relationships
across the world component has so much
to do with with this and and I think we
talk so much about technology technology
and software that sometimes we forget
about the human component which is so
emotional and so it doesn't operate on
on computer processors in binary there
are two things that fundamentally very
hard to change the first is the people
and the second is business models
somebody is operating in a particular
business model it's very hard to change
for example there are companies that
sell in part and they sell in parts from
a book and believe it or not even today
they are thinking like a book so again
those guys those people do have to
change because somebody will start in
buying and consuming and optimizing yeah
and that because they own the book and
because before somebody was buying this
part from this book because the book is
the only thing that he had and this
table so that's that's where he was
buying in vs. now when you add like
you're saying earlier and when you're
adding a component it's not it's from a
catalog or digital catalog and you know
where potentially it's being sourced
from what the human relationship is
where that's being sourced from adding
that change in the CAD file directly to
the Bill of Materials you know this is a
very very employee I can give you an
example today but you want to go to
airport from your home
and you run your vase or Google Maps it
can tell you that typically if you want
to be there an 8 a.m. on Tuesday you
need to leave your home at this time
because we know how much traffic it will
take you know all this did now think
about when factoring company want to do
something and having more or less
similar like imagine this right I'm
trying to build this and I'm using this
component and I know this component had
a failure rate of 5% under certain
conditions you know yes yes many things
yes this is this is a very good
comparison of when a manufacturing
company wants to make a decision kind of
like when we want to go to a certain
destination how can we optimize that
process for that manufacturing company
with the relationships evolve the data
foundation this is very cool like we're
very excited to see the future of open
BOM and thank you for teaching us about
it we really appreciate it thanks for
coming on to the show thank you very
much we really appreciate it thank you
thank you thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate you let us know
your thoughts in the comments below
Bill of Materials start talking to more
people about it start talking to more
people about what it's like to actually
manufacture goods like this and the data
foundations behind it
huge shout out to Co Fez Co fezzes links
are below as well Congress on the future
of engineering shop software check them
out and go and build the future everyone
support the artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in all our links are
below as well manifest your dreams into
the world we will see you soon
much love peace